that people get coveted
they'll likely be asymptomatic or feel
under the weather for a few days
let's be clear unvaccinated people
that are at a higher risk of getting
severely ill from covid
getting hospitalized
and dying
we are prepared for this moment
yesterday the president announced new
actions the administration is taking to
protect families
communities and hospitals as we face
omicron
these steps include more support for
hospitals including 1 000 military
troops deployed
hundreds of ambulances and help for
hospitals to ensure adequate supplies
equipment and beds
more testing including new federal sites
and a half a billion tests that will be
free to all americans
and more capacity to get shots and arms
including new mobile clinics
hundreds of additional vaccinators in
the field
and tens of thousands of new
appointments
let me reiterate what the president said
yesterday
this is not march 2020.
we have more tools than ever before to
protect people
vaccinations boosters testing
and treatments
today i want to give an update on
treatments
from day one our strategy has been to
fill the nation's medicine cabinet
with a diverse set of options to treat
people
let me walk through the three types of
treatments starting with monoclonal
antibody treatments which have proven to
be highly effective
since july we've deployed 2.7 million
monoclonal antibody treatment courses
to help keep people out of the hospital
and save lives
from the moment we learned of omicron we
began assessing our existing monoclonal
antibody treatments
and that learn and we learned that two
of the three existing treatments
are not effective against the new
variant
fortunately glaxosmithkline's monoclonal
antibody treatment is effective so we
acted quickly to secure more supply of
it
we're doubling more than doubling the
supply of gsk's monoclonal
to more than one million treatment
courses with three hundred thousand
treatment courses available in january
and we've already begun making this drug
available to every state and territory
next let me touch on a preventive
treatment from astrazeneca
which is especially important for
certain immunocompromised individuals at
high risk
many of these immunocompromised people
are not able to get the level of
protection they need from a vaccine
alone
we will have more than half a million
doses of astrazeneca's monoclonal
antibody treatments on hand in january
and we're preparing to purchase
significantly more across the next three
months
and finally let me provide an update on
antivirals
we got good news today with the
authorization of pfizer as antiviral
merck's pill if authorized along with
pfizer's newly authorized pill
had oral treatment options to our
nation's medicine cabinet
as soon as emerging science showed the
promise of these antivirals we acted
quickly
and aggressively to pre-purchase 10
million treatment courses of pfizer
and 3 million courses of work
for merck by end of january we
anticipate about 3 million treatment
courses available to send to states
if fda authorizes
the pfizer team has a very promising
and now authorized treatment
a pill that dramatically reduces the
risk of hospitalizations and death for
those at risk
we've purchased 10 million courses more
than anyone else in the world
according to pfizer the complex
chemistry involved in creating the
active ingredient in the pill
means production
takes about six to eight months
so supply of this product will ramp up
over the next several months
knowing that these pills take time to
manufacture
pfizer continues to increase their
production plans
and now that the pill is authorized
we'll have discussions to explore how we
can help them improve their
manufacturing capacity even further
by providing any resources needed
we will have 265 000 treatment courses
of pfizer available in january
with monthly totals of pills ramping up
across the year
and all 10 million treatment courses
delivered
by late summer
as quickly as pfizer gets the pills
manufactured and delivered we will
immediately provide them to states and
jurisdictions for distribution
just as we've done with vaccines and
monoclonal antibody treatments we will
ensure equity
is at the center of antiviral
distribution
we are not only urging states to ensure
equity in their own distribution plans
but we are also distributing antivirals
directly to community health centers
across the country
this will help ensure these life-saving
antivirals are available to the most
vulnerable communities
and hard-hit populations across the
country
in closing as we face omicron
the nation's medicine cabinet of
treatments gives us more options to
protect the american people
it's yet another reason this moment is
much different than march 2020.
we have tools to keep people safe
and we will continue using them to do so
with that over to dr wilinski
thank you jeff good afternoon as usual
i'd like to start by walking you through
today's data
the current seven-day daily average of
cases is about 149
300 cases per day an increase of about
25
over the previous week
the seven-day average of hospital
admissions is about 7 800 per day and
the seven-day average of deaths are
about 1200 per day which is an increase
of about 3.5 percent over the prior week
over the past several weeks cdc has
continued to closely monitor the
emergence of the omicron variant
currently over 85 countries have
detected omicron and on monday we
released updated data for the united
states which estimates that the omicron
variant represents approximately 73
percent of covet 19 cases in the united
states
and in some areas of the country omicron
has increased even further accounting
for an estimated 90 of cases in the
eastern atlantic states parts of the
midwest south and northern pacific
states
this rapid increase in the proportion of
omicron circulating around the country
is similar to what we've seen around the
world
although this is a reminder of continued
threat of covet 19 variants this
increase in omicron proportion is what
we anticipated and what we have been
preparing for
i know there are a lot of questions
about the omicron variant how to protect
yourselves our loved ones how to safely
gather with our families and friends
over the holidays
and you've heard me say before we know
what works against cloven 19 and it's
critically important that we implement
our proven multi-layer prevention
strategies
let me reiterate those four prevention
measures for you
get vaccinated get boosted
wear a mask in public indoor settings in
areas of substantial and high-risk
community transmission and take a test
before you gather
i know many parents are wondering how
they can keep their children safe for
the holidays if your child is five or
older get them vaccinated and if they
are younger than five years surround
them with adults and siblings who are
vaccinated boosted if eligible and
masking in public indoor settings
i also want to be sure people understand
the risks around holiday travel
holiday gatherings and risk of travel
really has less to do with the airplane
or car ride and much more to do with how
people from different households behave
in the weeks to days before meeting up
importantly consider gathering with
family and friends who are also
practicing similar proper prevention
measures
and as we have said before those who
remain unvaccinated are the most
vulnerable to covet 19.
cdc data now updated through november
when delta was the predominant strain
circulating demonstrated that an
unvaccinated person has a 10 times
greater risk of testing positive for
cova 19 and a 20 times greater risk of
dying from covet 19 when compared to
those who are fully vaccinated and
received their booster dose
although every day we are following more
and more studies emerging about the
omicron variant early data on the
vaccine is promising against omicron
especially when people are boosted
cobit 19 vaccines especially when
accompanied by a booster dose are likely
to protect against severe disease
hospitalization and death
still
we know we will continue to hear more
about people who get infected who are
vaccinated these people may get mild or
asymptomatic infections and could
unknowingly spread those infections to
others
again this means it is important for
everyone regardless of vaccination
status to wear a mask in public indoor
settings in communities of substantial
or high transmission
and i would encourage people to take an
at-home cover 19 test ahead of time to
help protect you and your family and
friends who may be at greater risk of
covet 19 or severe outcomes
evidence has repeatedly shown that these
prevention measures when layered
together work
so again if you're wondering how to stay
healthy and protect your loved ones this
winter please get vaccinated get boosted
wear a mask in public indoor settings
and take a covet 19 test before
gathering with others we're to critical
point and how well these measures are
implemented by all of us caring for
ourselves and for one another will
largely determine the outlook of the
coming weeks and months ahead thank you
happy holidays i'll now turn things over
to dr fauci
thank you very much dr wolinski
what i'd like to do now is just spend
just a few minutes on underscoring and
reiterating some of the important
principles
that dr wolenski had mentioned i'm going
to touch on four areas very quickly
transmissibility severity the evasion of
immunity by vaccines
and the potential impact on therapeutics
i will point out that there is a
relationship between interpreting
the relationship between
transmissibility and severity and i'll
explain what i mean in a moment next
slide
no doubt this is a highly transmissible
infection these are the latest data that
we get from the cdc
about the omicron variant that is
sequenced in the united states isolates
it is now about 73 plus percent
and speaking to governors from other
regions of the country
in some they're even as high as 80 to 90
so there is no doubt
that we are dealing with a highly
transmissible virus for the reason
as jeff mentioned just a moment ago that
we expect that there will be continuing
to have
a substantial increase in cases next
slide
now we get to the idea of severity these
are data from our south african
colleagues who are clearly been showing
now in conversations we've had and now
in this recent publication
that in fact it appears that in the
context of south africa
there is a decrease in the severity
compared to
delta
both in the relationship and ratio
between hospitalizations and the number
of infections
the duration of hospital stay
a need for supplemental oxygen therapy
recently literally yesterday there was
another paper that came out from
scotland which appears to validate and
verify the data that are in south africa
this is good news however we must wait
to see what happens in our own
population which has its own
demographic considerations
i would point out that even if you have
a diminution
in severity if you have a much larger
number of individual cases
the fact that you have so many more
cases
might actually obviate the effect of it
being less
severe and that's one of the reasons why
the president in his remarks yesterday
spoke about how we are going to
supplement the capability
of hospitals to respond to the
possibility that there might be a run on
the need for hospitalization
next slide
now let's talk about some of the immune
evasion we've mentioned this in
different briefings before
but just to reiterate there's no doubt
that there's a marked reduction in
neutralizing activity against omicron
when you look at the two dose mrna
vaccines when you compare omicron to
earlier variants such as delta
however and here again
why we emphasize the importance of
booster shots
the anti-omicron activity is about 20 to
40 fold higher
in serif from boosted vaccinees
versus the peak in individuals who had a
two-dose vaccine
this is validated by the clinical data
which shows that the vaccine efficacy as
we all know from previous studies
of a symptomatic infection of a two-dose
mrna
wanes over time
however there's a moderate to high
effectiveness about 75 percent
seen in the early period after a booster
dose and very likely higher
when it comes to hospitalization
and severe disease
next slide
a quick word now on something that jeff
mentioned
is namely the treatments that are
available unfortunately but
understandably with the degree of
mutations that we have with omicron some
of the monoclonal antibodies
shown on the slide here
very likely will not work against
omicron
and those are shown in the first two
under monoclonal antibody
fortunately the gsk veer product
satravamab
looks like it is will well positioned to
be used as a treatment against omicron
and then the az product also is likely
small molecule antivirals
are available now you heard the recent
approval of an eua of pax lavid
of note and under appreciated is
remdessevier is already fully approved
and is available in a three-day course
which in a recent study showed to
dramatically diminish the need for
hospitalization
guidelines on this will be now
re-examined by the nih guidelines
committee and you'll be hearing more
about recommendations how to utilize
these
if i can have the last slide
i want to again just reiterate what dr
wolinski said about prevention which is
a multi-layered
comprehensive process
the hallmark of which is vaccination
now one of the questions that dr
wolinski and i and dr murthy and others
get asked very frequently is that right
now as we get to the christmas holiday
in the new years
would it be safe for individuals who are
vaccinated who are boosted to get
together with family in the setting of
the home
the answer to that is yes an extra level
of protection would be the testing that
dr wolenski measured but i want to make
sure this is not confused
with going to a large
gathering and there are many of these
parties that have 30 40 50 people
in which you do not know the vaccination
status of individuals
those are the kind of functions in the
context of covid
and particularly in the context of
omicron that you do not want to go to so
to the extent possible we urge you to
stay away from those situations that
could put you at a higher risk
i'll stop there and back to you jeff
well thanks doctors with that let's open
it up for some questions kevin
thanks jeff uh let's try to get through
as many questions as we possibly can
first let's go to peter sullivan at the
hill
hi thanks um i wanted to ask on the
supplies of the new pfizer treatment
pill
there have been some experts calling for
the administration to just do more to
increase supply for example enlisting
other manufacturers the way
merck is helping awake make the j j
vaccine
so you're not just relying on pfizer's
uh capacity alone i have you considered
that at all or is there more steps you
know the administration can take to
boost the supply yeah um and and i might
also have dr fauci talk some about the
synthesis process which takes months to
do
we know the pfizer team is
hard at work
ramping up production
and
everyone agrees this is a very promising
antiviral
and therefore
we want to make sure that production is
ramped up as quickly as possible
according to the company
the complex chemistry involved in
creating the active ingredient in the
pill
means the production takes as i
mentioned about six to eight months now
the pill is authorized we will have
discussions to explore how we can help
them improve their manufacturing
capacity even further by providing any
resources that they need
as quickly as pfizer gets the pills
manufactured and delivered we will
immediately we will be immediately
providing them to states and
jurisdictions for
distribution so the bottom line is today
is
an exciting development and we applaud
the
american company for their innovation
we do have 10 million
doses
ordered which is the largest amount of
any country in the world and 265 000
treatment regimens will be available to
us in january anything you want to add
there dr fauci
uh well jeff just what you said i mean
the very good news is that we have a
product now that has about a 90 efficacy
in preventing hospitalization
but the sobering news is unfortunately
it is really a quite complicated and
complex
synthetic process which we will be
working with the company to figure out
how we can help alleviate the stress of
the long duration that it takes to make
it and hopefully we'll be able to
shorten that process by working closely
with them
next question
tamara keith at npr
thank you so much for taking my question
i'm wondering
the who is telling people to curtail
their holiday plans
why isn't the us government doing that
also and and also
where is the cdc on modifying the
definition of fully vaccinated to
include boosters
uh dr wilinski on holiday and
[Music]
modifying the definition
yeah i think that you just heard from dr
fauci as to how we are recommending
people modify their holiday plan
certainly we're not advocating for large
events as um and so i think that this is
a modification we also have given clear
guidance as to what we believe is a safe
way to gather we do want families to be
together to be able to be together this
holiday season and so to do so we're
really encouraging people to be
vaccinated to be boosted and to practice
all of those prevention strategies
before they gather so they can maximize
their the safety of their holiday
gathering as well as that reassurance of
a test with regard to your second
question um our guidance right now is
very clear
cdc recommends strongly recommends that
people who are eligible for a booster go
get a booster that is everyone above the
ages of 16 um boosting at greater than
six months if you're um if you receive
the pfizer mr or moderna vaccine and of
course greater than two months if you
receive the j j vaccine we're looking at
the definition right now um and you know
more to come there but just to be very
clear um
our recommendations are to get boosted
next question please
go to jeff selene at cnn
thank you for taking my question i was
wondering um if if jeff or
the doctors could point to one thing in
the last month that you could have done
differently to avoid where
the nation is right now on the cusp of
christmas
dr fauci anything to add there
well i don't think i can pick out one
thing that we could have done any time
that you put the effort that we're
putting in we always
are the the strongest self-critics of
could we have done something better
could we have some done something
more
quickly
or more uh thoroughly and you know
when you say i can't think of anything i
don't want anyone to think that we think
we've done everything perfectly but i
don't think i could point one thing out
in the last month
i think we've been intensively involved
in getting the response to the omicron
variant
we jumped all over it all of us spent
the entire
thanksgiving weekend
getting enough information to be able to
respond in an appropriate way
to omicron so again
admittedly we can always do better but i
can't think of something specifically
that we would have done differently
next question
let's go to meg tour cnbc
well thanks um going back to the pfizer
wonder if if you can walk through how
patients should uh try to get this drug
um the fact that they have to get a test
result quickly and take the drug within
five days of symptoms a lot of folks
don't have primary care doctors so will
there be telemedicine or some some way
to get it through the pharmacy how do
you look at that and then with the sort
of limited supply of it at the beginning
it is indicated just for high-risk
people but should there be
prioritization even within those groups
like by vaccination status why don't i
talk for a second about the distribution
plan and then over to dr
fauci for the medical questions as we've
done with
vaccines and monoclonals we'll
distribute
these treatments these pills in a fair
and equitable way now that they've been
authorized by the fda
the antivirals will be provided to
states and jurisdictions at no charge
on a pro rata basis to quickly to get
get that supply in the field
as i mentioned in my comments as part of
the administration's commitment
to equity we are also distributing
antiviral pills pfizer directly to
federally qualified community health
centers across all 50 states and that
will ensure that these life-saving
antivirals are available at some of the
most vulnerable
in some of the most vulnerable
communities and hard-hit populations
across the country over to you dr fauci
for the medical part of this
yeah well jeff and and and it is a
obviously a very difficult situation
when you have a limited supply
for that reason we've asked the nih
guidelines committee to put together a
recommendation of when someone comes in
with an acute infection and is in a risk
group which is what you want this to be
for since we have a limited supply that
we would have a prioritization of what
the best approach would be it almost
certainly will be
a physician writing a prescription for
someone who within the first three days
of notable symptoms of kovid and is in a
high risk group to get it but those
guidelines which will not only be
limited to what you would do with
paxlavid but also whether or not it
would might be more appropriate to
recommend remdesa beer which can be
given in a three-day course or
one of the monoclonal antibodies that
work so stay tuned this will be coming
out shortly from the guidelines
committee
next question please
let's go to ricardo at the ap
can you hear me
yep
okay thank you for taking my question
and it's for dr walensky
and my question is um
the president
that we're gonna see more and more cases
involving on that i'm sorry vaccinated
people
in every workplace he said even in the
white house and anecdotally people are
seeing that with various political and
sports celebrities who are vaccinated
getting coveted
can you tell us what proportion of cases
currently
are
represented by vaccinated people in
other words what proportion of covet
cases are vaccinated people
how that compares with what proportion
of hospitalized patients and deaths
and
can you give us a timeline for a
decision
on
making
the definition of fully vaccinated to
mean boosted as well because it seems
like that's an urgent question for the
average american
yeah thank you for that question ricardo
so um
what i can tell you is that you are 10
times more likely to have a case of
covet if you are unvaccinated compared
to if you are vaccinated and boosted you
are 20 times more likely to die of covid
if you are unvaccinated compared to if
you're vaccinated and boosted and yes we
know with omicron that has more
mutations and is a bit able to evade our
vaccines better that we are going to see
vaccinated and even boosted people have
breakthrough cases and they will have
breakthrough cases with mild
and mild disease or perhaps even
asymptomatic disease and what i would
say is that is those vaccines working
and working well because those vaccines
are working to prevent
really severe disease and to prevent
hospitalizations and deaths
as for your second question that
evaluation is currently underway um and
you know more soon but to be very clear
our recommendations are to get boosted
next
question let's go to martin grappy at
usa today
i want to ask jeff about the guidance
coming out next month on how insurers
will pay for at home co-bid tests
does the administration have the ability
to require health plans to work with the
pharmacies to make these tests free to
consumers at the counter so that you
don't have to file for reimbursement
after buying the test yeah so that's
very much a good question that's very
much work in process and all ideas like
the idea that you
mentioned are on the table and that will
be worked through across the next couple
of weeks with clear guidance on how
american consumers with private health
insurance can be easily reimbursed for
their test
next question
carol stollberg new york times
hi thank you for taking this question
this is directed at dr fauci
um dr felicia i wonder if you could
address this idea
that somehow omicron is a blessing in
disguise a south korean health official
said omicron could be viewed as a signal
of this pandemic nearing its end
if it is proven to be more contagious
but less deadly
and i'm wondering in the context of the
data that you presented from south
africa today what is your view of that
well i think that's a supposition that
might i i would hate to say a blessing
in disguise i never thought of a virus
ever that could infect and kill people
to be a blessing in any way
but if you're talking about would it be
preferable
to have
omicron be totally pervasive and be
relatively low degree of severity
yes obviously that would be preferable
but it's dangerous business to be able
to rely
on what you perceive as a lower degree
of severity
having said that
it is conceivable cheryl
that if omicron takes over
and you get a good immune response to
omicron and you do not
wind up getting severity as much as with
delta
that we could wind up
with a virus that's pervasive that does
not cause severity and that people would
get enough immune response to
that you would then wind up having a
lesser degree of morbidity and mortality
that is conceivable
but you don't want to count on it you
can't count on anything when you're
dealing with a virus that has fooled us
so many times before
next question
last question let's go to josh wingrove
at bloomberg
thank you very much jeff france said
today that they're not going to use
merck's pill and are going to wait
for pfizer's pill if the fda does
authorize merck will you
uh use it
in other words will you follow the fda
or is there any review that would happen
afterwards
about whether one pill would be better
than the other and dr volinsky we
reported on the weekend that the data on
vaccine counts are off nationally
because of a range of factors but
essentially we're underestimating both
the fully vaccinated and boosted but
also the unvaccinated wonder if you have
any idea how big the gap is in other
words do you know what the true number
is thank you
well you know obviously on the merc uh
anti-viral pill we will follow the fda's
lead and as dr fauci talked about the
nih guidance
on how the pill would be used if
authorized by the fda and as i mentioned
earlier we have purchased three million
of the merck pills
uh over to you dr wolinski
yeah thank you for that question josh um
so we work with states local governments
local jurisdictions and work to get the
best data that are possible from those
local jurisdictions and compile the
immunization data from many different
places from pharmacies from healthcare
providers from large database large
electronic health records and do so from
all different states and jurisdictions
um we work closely with those states and
jurisdictions to update and provide us
the best possible data that they can and
then we compile it to give you the
american people the best reporting that
we can what i can say is that there's
one better way to to get the data better
and that is if people can bring in their
vaccination cards that really does help
us to record what dose they are on and
when they are not able to provide those
vaccination cards it makes it harder for
local jurisdictions to assess that so
we're working with local jurisdictions
and governments and and health care
providers in order to do so and we'd ask
the american people to help us by
improve our data by bringing in their
vaccination cards
the one thing i'd add there josh is you
know as you said there may be some
situations where shots were
misclassified the first shot as a
booster shot was i think an example you
gave but i think
the top line number
475 million
total shots and arms administered i
think it's actually higher than that at
this point approaching 500 million that
reflects the total
tremendous progress that we've made and
what we know most importantly is getting
more and more people vaccinated more
people boosted
is the most important thing to do so i
know cdc is making progress on the data
but that top line number approaching 500
million total shots and arms is very
encouraging we need to continue to grow
that each and every day
so i want to thank everybody and i hope
everybody has a safe and happy holiday
thank you
thank you
you